wix is extremely powerful and if you're
just starting out then you shouldn't be
skipping this video and you definitely
shouldn't be skipping this incredible
website builder now there's a reason
most people will tell you to start your
ecommerce business or any business
online with shopify and shopify is an
amazing asset however wix is downright
the easiest platform and the easiest
website builder to start any business no
matter what you have in mind especially
if you're just starting out in the game
so today i'm going to give you my top
five reasons of why i still choose wix
to start every single one of my
companies and every single one of my
business ideas at the very start of the
life cycle of that company what's going
on guys my name is david thomas welcome
back to the channel on this channel we
talk all things technology and
architecture today we're taking a deep
dive into wix and how you can implement
it in to your business idea i'm going to
be focusing some of these ideas around
architecture because well that's what
this channel is about now enough of my
fluffing around let's actually turn
around to these two screens and go
through the best reasons of why you
should be starting your business idea
with wix now when people are starting
off with picking a website builder they
usually talk about price and wix is up
there with the rest of them it's pretty
comparable to squarespace and it's
pretty comparable to shopify however the
best thing about wix is quite often
you'll find yourself with a 50 discount
for the first year which therefore makes
it one of the cheapest websites for the
first year for you to test and
fundamentally analyze your business idea
to see if it's worth growing and if it's
actually going to work so most of the
time you're never going to find any of
that discount on the wix main webpage
you can dive into google and look for a
discount code and often you'll find them
pretty quickly there is genuinely a 50
off sale most of the time on the wix
homepage as well so if you're actually
signed into wix you'll see on this right
hand side premium that sometimes says 50
off on certain selections so that's one
of the reasons why i always like to
start off with wix secondly wix is an
incredibly easy to understand and easy
to use website build up for example you
can click on something drag it across
and that's exactly where that text is
going to be if i want to move that back
or undo it's very intuitive command or
control z undoes that action the same
thing goes with pretty much anything
that we want to design and move around
we just click on it and move it a lot of
website builders are fundamentally
programmed to be code based which means
you have to understand at least the
basics to be able to move things outside
of the parameters they usually allow you
to in wix you can simply scroll down
click on anything move it out of the way
and change it how you want so without
having to learn too many things it's
very intuitive and very quick and easy
to build whatever you're trying to
achieve
now if you're in a hurry and really want
to develop a website in a matter of
seconds you can literally jump on wix
adi go through the general process of
building a website you get stuck on this
page here which basically says let me
create it myself or let wix do all the
work for me if you click let wix do all
the work for me and select a few color
schemes for your templates it'll
basically spit out an entire website
with pre-filled out information that you
can go into and customize in a matter of
minutes and have up and running within
their half an hour versus a full website
custom build which could take weeks and
weeks and weeks so if you are basically
just trying to get online trying to get
a presence trying to pump out your
google seos you can use wix adi to
automatically create a website for you
that looks half decent and in my
personal opinion looks a hell of a lot
better than some of the very old
websites that are still up and running
and making an absolute fortune wix also
makes creating your products and your
product page super super simple unlike
other website designers where you have
to go through a whole series of
different information to actually get a
product up and running on wix you can
basically fill in the basic information
put up a picture put in your price and
away you go by the time you press that
save button it's already live on your
website so for example if i was to go to
my website go straight to my store page
you can see that everything is
automatically populated so that one
checklist for architects who are looking
to do a construction checklist and save
themselves a hell of a lot of time a
little plug there
you can basically get a website looking
like that
with very minimal input from you so what
you're actually creating is half a page
of text input to be able to generate a
full website add to cart all of that
background information and background
coding done 100 for you last but not
least my favorite part about wix is the
simple seos now obviously starting out
in a website builder you probably don't
know anything about seos but they are
what generates your leads from google
and if you want to have a successful
business you want to be able to pump in
or as many people from google because
it's free traffic if you simply go to
your website builder click on seo basics
you can define how google sees your page
now you don't need to be an expert at
this you don't need to show
any knowledge of coding or any
understanding of seos all you have to do
is pre-fill in this information exactly
how you want it let google index this
page and it will appear like this
directly on google if i type in
davidsonwich architect on google you'll
find exactly what your website needs to
look like you can go through every
single page and change the seos
individually on every single page so it
ranks significantly better on google and
all of a sudden you're beating your
competitors hands down every single time
but anyway that is all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video if you did hit the
like button hit the subscribe button and
like always i'll see you next monday